la fusion des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine se prépare hier le
conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental et ses conseillers
départementaux se sont réunis pour
organiser la fusion prévue fin 2017
c'est une chose assez difficile parce
que c'est par seulement une fusion ce
qui ne veut rien dire
c'est l'organisation de nos territoires
de manière à évidemment avoir à la fois
une proximité une compétence parce que
les voiries de nos deux départements
sont très différentes
bien bien évidemment le dans les
yvelines la voirie et est une souvent
une voirie rurale beaucoup moins
coûteuse que dans les hauts-de-seine qui
est une j'arrive beaucoup plus urbaine
beaucoup plus soumises à des contraintes
mais tous les conseillers départementaux
ne sont pas favorables à cette fusion
pour gabriel massou conseil
départemental front de gauche des
hauts-de-seine le projet obsolète et
devrait plutôt s'orienter vers un
partenariat avec tous les départements
franciliens
il faudra faire beaucoup de
communication pour convaincre les
populations qu'il faut aller vers la
fusion c'est assez révélateur que les
populations de notre département chez
lui les hauts de seine ne vis pas au
quotidien
cette unité hauts-de-seine yvelines
alors qu'ils vont beaucoup plus à paris
pour certains en seine-saint-denis
donald val d'oise où elles valent demain
voilà il ya une diversité quotidienne de
déplacement de vie de culture de le
sortie qui fait que la java pourquoi en
à ce type de réflexion que dans leurs
retranchements avec les yvelines à
l'issue de cette réunion 14 millions
d'euros seront alloués dans l'année à la
voirie l'archéologie préventive et
l'adoption